[Music]
be careful what you wish for parker
hello peter all right anyone see
anything new this time there's a black
cat on the wall at 56 seconds
could be a felicia hardy clue you know
the black cat i think we noticed that
around past number
246 then no maybe we do another round of
0.75 speed you ever wonder whether we're
starting to miss the forest for the
trees on these things you mean apart
from being in a video production bunker
all day and thus seeing neither forests
nor trees no no no i mean like sure
there are easter eggs in the trailers
they get paid off later but i mean
really how deep does the rabbit hole
truly go i mean how much of this is real
are they really thinking this hard
planning all this out or is it just us
speculating grasping at straws just
looking for the next little detail that
we can desperately cling to in order to
claim another 15 minutes of relevance
are we just wasting our lives watching
the spider-man trailer 300 times to pick
apart every last detail what's today's
date again
august 23rd
why
[Music]
[Applause]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that knows you'll always find
your way home to our like and subscribe
button speaking of likes holy cow did
people like that spider-man no way home
trailer in 24 hours the thing amassed a
total of
355 million views annihilating the
previous record holder avengers endgame
with its mere 298 million and it's not
hard to see why a new spider-man sequel
is in a pedigree by itself it's not a
prequel about a character who's already
died it's not an origin story for a
character no one's ever heard of it's
not whatever eternals is trying to be
which gotta be honest they're at the
final trailer stage and i still don't
see any semblance of a story there none
of those things instead it's the payoff
to one of cinema's greatest most recent
cliffhanger starring the most beloved
marvel superhero of all time that alone
has got to get people more excited than
tim burton in a spirit halloween store
then add to that a potential multiversal
crossover with resurrected free disney
villains and classic spider-man and yeah
you got something that's going to make
thanos numbers look like chump change
you know that if toby mcguire and andrew
garfield are actually in this thing one
moment of them doing the spider-man
point at each other and the internet
will melt literally just pull up and
melt on the floor oh and here's the
other thing everyone in the blog is
fears for getting into the spider-verse
yeah that's also a sony property spoiler
alert there's absolutely a 100 chance
that miles morales and a spider-verse
reference will appear in this movie what
i'm really hoping for here is that
there's a fully animated segment within
this film but either way you don't just
waste this chance to promote your other
massive spider-man property about
multiversal crossovers within this movie
about spider-man and multiversal
crossovers anyway now that we've all
seen it or i guess i shouldn't say all
but again
355 million people in 24 hours is about
as close to all as we get in terms of
unifying experiences outside of course
like the planet exploding or i don't
know the mcrib coming back a lot of us
have also noticed that something feels
kind of off about what's actually
happening within this trailer like why
would a fugitive peter parker wanted for
murder actually go back to his high
school why is it snowing indoors why is
doctor strange lying to wong about a
dangerous spell and when did flash
thompson get that die job it's not so
much that the apparent sequence of
events don't make sense it's that the
actions of the people making them don't
seem to align with how we necessarily
expect them to act something is going on
here and there are already a ton of
interesting theories circulating is
doctor strange being manipulated is he a
variant from another universe is this
some kind of it's a wonderful life fake
wish fulfillment dream scenario to teach
peter a lesson about why he's wrong to
turn to magic to solve his problems or
is this the evil doctor strange from
episode 4 of what if who is also
secretly mephisto and the thing is i
like all these theories i think all of
them are actually hitting pretty close
to the truth and we'll talk about them
all here in a minute but i've also got a
theory that looks just a little bit
further my spider sense tells me no way
home isn't just a huge spider-man sequel
it's also setting up yet another
spider-man reboot okay so for this
theory to make any sense we first need
to talk about the essence of movie
trailers i mean do you even know why
they're called trailers they're shown in
front of movies after all so what's the
deal well obviously the whole business
of advertising movies has changed a lot
over the years back in the really early
pre-television days when going to the
movies was an all-day event studios
would show two of their movies in a row
back-to-back with a lower budget less
well-known one going first this was the
origin of the term b-movie bees have
never been afraid to change the world i
mean what about b columbus b gandhi for
jesus
it's time to stop previews of coming
attractions then came after this be real
aka they were trailing the preceding
show hence the term trailers but their
goal has and will always be selling the
audience on the next big upcoming movie
and the one technique that's proven more
effective than any other is building a
sense of mystery no joke we think of
this as a fairly recent trend but check
out this old trailer from the movie
psycho where the director alfred
hitchcock just walks you around the set
and makes everything into a cliffhanger
a quiet little motel perfectly harmless
looking when in fact it has now become
the scene of the crime oh by the way
this picture has great significance
because
uh it goes on like this for six minutes
nowadays things are a little bit fancier
than this with digital editing allowing
studios to fake entire scenes just to
get that trailer narrative that they
want in the trailers for infinity war
they created a team shot with the hulk
that was never in the movie they changed
the number of the stones in the infinity
gauntlet so people wouldn't know which
order the scenes took place in i mean
sure this fight on the train from the no
way home trailer looks like spidey's
fighting doctor strange but maybe
they're both fighting someone who hasn't
been added to the finished fx yet heck
is that even doctor strange mordo is
still at large he dresses pretty much
like strange does so it wouldn't be that
tough of an edit to deep fake out same
thing with this woman who awkwardly
looks pasted in there and doesn't move
it could be some spidey sense slow down
effect or maybe this is just a stand-in
pasted in over someone who might have
been an actual spoiler the point is well
yeah doctor strange agreeing to cast a
super risky spell for an impulsive
teenager and then getting mad at him
when he continues to be impulsive about
it really seems like it should want more
context in reality we don't have any
context for any of this it just feels
like we do because the trailers editing
did a great job using a story structure
to sell a micro narrative about the
general premise or as much of the
premise as they want us to be aware of
right now i can practically guarantee
you that doctor strange's lying about
the dangers of messing with the
multiverse comes from probably the final
minutes of the movie what we do know is
that peter's secret identity was
revealed at the end of far from home
it's messing up his life and the lives
of his loved ones and so he's asking dr
strange to mind wipe the planet and if
you know your spider-man comics well
that premise is gonna make you sit bolt
upright pretty much the exact plot of
one of the most controversial spider-man
story arcs of all time one more day this
one has gotten talked about a lot so i'm
not gonna linger on it for too long but
for those of you who are unfamiliar i'm
going to give you the quick recap
originally published in 2007 one more
day was part of the aftermath of civil
wars storyline where just like it
appeared in the movies the team fights
over whether superheroes should have to
register themselves in order to protect
the public in the comics heroes who
initially supported iron man's
pro-registration team had to publicly
reveal their secret identities as part
of the agreement so peter being on team
stark is something that he almost
immediately regrets and that my friends
is why you always have to read the fine
print and since every villain now knew
how to find spider-man ant-may catches a
bullet from a hitman lapsing into a
fatal coma brought on by her injuries
and you know probably being like a
thousand years old at this point after
going to everyone he knows to try and
fix it including doctor strange he gets
hit up by someone who says that they can
help mephisto aka the devil who offers
to infernal magic ant-may back to life
provided peter allows him to erase the
other thing spider-man loves the most
the entire history of his marriage to
mary jane watson something which
wouldn't you know it marvel's editors at
the time had also been trying
unsuccessfully to erase for over a
decade spider-man says yes and he and
mary jane are allowed to be together for
one more day that's the name of the
movie and then peter wakes up in a
rebooted world oh and also his web
shooters aren't organic anymore which
was a thing for a while and yeah this
story is one of the reasons why so many
people are always looking for mephisto
to show up but this time with no way
home well yeah the mephisto theories
really seem to fit the broad strokes of
the story work peter wants the world to
forget his identity he makes a deal with
a magic user chaos ensues then of course
you have the smaller details like the
guy holding up the devil horns
caricature of peter parker in the
protest scene with the text that reads
devil in disguise i mean that's not even
trying to hide it at this point i think
that marvel knows that every trailer
they release needs a mephisto easter egg
and not only that but this theory would
also explain all the weird stuff
happening with doctor strange in the
trailer you see in episode 4 of marvel's
what if we're introduced to an alternate
version of doctor strange nicknamed
armani come this way sorcerer armani and
labeled in the subtitles as strange
supreme in this episode he attempts to
use the time stone to save his love
christine who in this timeline died in
the accident that broke strange's hands
from the original mcu we're told that
the moment of her death is called an
absolute point something that cannot be
changed because doing so would create a
paradox her death is an absolute point
in time
absolutely
unchangeable if you erase her death
you never start your journey you cannot
reverse an absolute point strange being
the stubborn guy he is decides that all
he needs is to become more powerful and
so he summons a slew of creatures in
order to absorb their magic i need to
borrow your powers do you mind sharing a
tentacle or two his transformation at
this point is uh fairly demonic someone
even goes so far as to call him the
devil eventually he becomes powerful
enough to shatter the absolute point
except there's one problem like breaking
a load-bearing beam in a house
demolishing that moment in time causes
the universe to collapse around him as
strange supreme struggles to keep the
universe intact the very fabric of
reality crushes him into a small purple
gem now i bet you're thinking so what
matpat this sounds like a complete story
alternate universe doctor strange
destroyed his own universe out of
arrogance story closed right well maybe
not right theorists for one we hear this
line at the end of the spider-man
trailer be careful what you wish for
parker it's a warning that would
believably come from a doctor strange
who just wished to have his love back
and sacrificed his soul and entire
universe to get it only for that to
backfire horribly also notice how no way
homes doctor strange still wears the eye
of agamotto something that i don't know
thanos destroyed back in infinity war
now who has an intact version of that
charm strange supreme in what if and the
similarities just keep going wong in the
what if episode gives a warning that
strange immediately ignores pretty much
paralleling the exact same scene in the
spider-man trailer well
i'm going to start the kettle i suggest
you join me before you do something
reckless strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
and at the end of what if strange
supreme cries out to uwatu the watcher
to do something showing that this
version of strange is powerful enough to
see and talk to an interdimensional
being but uwatu claims that he can't
help the guy because do and so would
endanger all other universes i could
warn him intervene
but the fate of his universe is not
worth risking the safety of all others
this proves that if armani escaped his
purple gem prison he would have the
knowledge and ability and motive to
tamper with the very fabric of reality
exactly what strange is doing in the no
way home trailer and all of this all of
it is without even going into how having
a demonic doctor strange filled the role
of mephisto would help introduce the
character while also circumventing
china's heavy censorship around the
devil and a cult something that we
talked extensively about in a previous
one division episode linked right mia so
this has gotta be it right the devil
himself mephisto finally steps out from
the mcu shadows set up in an alternate
timeline presented in what if to so
chaos launch spider-man into a
multiversal war against his greatest
enemies and um and uh what exactly you
see that's the problem with the whole
strange isn't himself theory train that
i've been seeing going around it's too
complicated spider-man is too mainstream
of a character and too important of a
franchise to get bogged down with things
having to be set up in a disney plus
series the offshoot franchises have to
be in service of the movies not vice
versa we can't set up a multiverse and
multiple enemies and multiple spider-men
and also dr strange actually being the
devil all in this one movie it is just
way too much plus you don't even have to
go that far there's a better fit for
this story found in the comics one that
doesn't require mephisto and one that
quite honestly more closely follows what
we see happening in the trailer i don't
know why no one's brought this one up in
public discourse yet but the clear
parallel to the story in no way home
isn't one more day it's the story's
follow-up the lesser-known one moment in
time now people don't tend to know this
one because one more day was so
unpopular that a lot of fans refused to
acknowledge anything that came after it
in the timeline but stop me for a minute
if any of these plot points sound
familiar after peter parker's identity
gets out his family and loved ones are
suddenly put into danger and he goes not
to mephisto but rather to dr strange for
help asking strange to erase the world's
memories of his identity as spider-man
to quote from the comic i blew it
strange i put my family in the
crosshairs i need the world to forget
that i'm spider-man strange then
disappears to think it through just like
in these shots from the trailer after
consulting with mr fantastic and iron
man doctor strange agrees he creates a
protective bubble for peter to be
shielded from the spell and starts his
magic and oh wait wouldn't you know it
peter starts having second thoughts
regrets his decision and decides to pull
mary jane into the protective bubble so
she doesn't lose her memories which in
turn causes chaos so to recap we've got
ourselves peter asking doctor strange to
do a memory scrub and then changing his
mind mid abracadabra because he's torn
about losing his loved ones sounds like
we might have found ourselves the real
source of this story in the end mary
jane is like you should have let me
forget too and tldr the lesson is that
peter needed to grow up and not rely on
magic to solve his problems to quote
from the story i should have listened to
doc strange when he told me there were a
lot of things he could do with his magic
but i didn't and he was right in the end
i just needed to grow up and face the
inevitable which to me sounds exactly
like the moral of a spider-man growing
up and becoming an adult story like we
have with tom holland in no way home and
to get there you know he just needs to
hop between a few different universes to
talk to older wiser spiderman who've
been in his shoes before but wait
there's one final universe that we've
neglected to mention in this entire
theory and that's ours and this is where
the reboot stuff comes in you see the
world seems to have forgotten that
disney and sony still have an awkward
step parent relationship with spider-man
sure disney may have convinced sony to
give him streaming rights to spider-man
through 2026 but what about the other
deal the one where sony still owns the
movie rights to all of spider-man but
they co-produce the main ones with
marvel studios so they can be in the mcu
as far as anyone saying publicly that's
apparently still set to expire when tom
holland's current contract for this solo
movie as well as one more yet unknown
marvel appearance are concluded which
means one thing it's quickly becoming
renegotiation time and that means
there's always a chance that sony
decides to take its web covered ball and
go home which brings us to our other
theory today whatever happens in
spider-man no way home whichever other
villains show up whichever other
spider-man appear by whatever means
wanda maximoff zaps in during the
post-credits scene to set us up for the
multiverse of madness this story is
going to wrap up in such a way that well
there can be a path forward for tom
holland's peter parker he can also be
soft rebooted as a different peter
parker or heck a different spider-man
like miles morales if and when things
between disney and sony don't go well i
mean you think it's just a coincidence
they chose to go all in on a premise
that's based on two comic story lines
that literally were created to reboot
the character consider this peter says
that he wants the world to forget that
mysterio revealed his identity but
immediately interrupts the spell to
preserve certain memories for certain
people it's clear that what he really
wants is the opposite of that famous
uncle ben line to have the power of
being spider-man without the
responsibility that comes with it he
wants to be spider-man but also wants
personal connections that aren't put at
risk just like peter did in one moment
in time and also in sam raimi's
spider-man 2 and also again in amazing
spider-man 2. tom holland in this movie
is gonna have to learn that you can't
have it both ways he's gonna have to
make a choice problem is you trying to
live two different lives the longer you
do it the more dangerous it becomes
he'll have to give up one part or the
other of his double life and the thing
about that is basically any decision he
makes in that scenario in any direction
completely upends the spider-man status
quo staying as spider-man and memory
wiping everyone well that turns every
character relationship into a clean
slate moving forward as spider-man
without a memory wipe he's gonna have to
distance himself from his loved ones
because they're now in danger giving up
the mask entirely to someone else so he
can live a normal life with his loved
ones yeah that's big reboot time i'm
sure you all can think of more than that
but what all those scenarios have in
common is that they're open-ended and
reboot-ready if sony or disney start
having second thoughts about the joint
custody agreement the bottom line is
this in order for this story to conclude
in a satisfying impactful definitive way
that also leaves the franchise able to
proceed spider-man himself is gonna be
the one who can't go back to the way
things were whose only choices will be
to go forward into a radically changed
world in the end it's peter who'll truly
have no way home but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and cuts
[Music]
you